Christmas arrived early at Founders
coffee this year in more ways than one
and here to tell us how you can give and
receive is Susie Newman from Founders
coffee and Julia Kofi marketing
coordinator for the Ronald McDonald
House Charities welcome you two happy
holidays first of all this is a great
program over at Founders it's it tell us
what it's called and what does it do so
we have a giving drink every month a
dollar from each drink sold if the
giving drink goes to a charity a local
charity this drink we have Santa's
cookies so we have a oatmeal cookie
latte and a sugar cookie latte both
really good so buy the drink a dollar
the proceeds goes to your charity that's
so nice that you're doing that and
Ronald McDonald House Charities they are
fantastic tell us a little bit about
their mission and how this money is
going to help yeah so the Ronald
McDonald House is an extremely special
place we provide a home away from home
for families traveling to Las Vegas to
receive very critical medical treatment
for their child so when you buy a giving
drink you're helping provide
Transportation meals rides to and from
the hospital as well as housing so it's
really awesome I've done just like
charity work there before and like
making lunches in the kitchen like it's
such a great place and so loving so this
is going to help a lot for you guys of
course yeah and if people do want to
make a donation can they just come in
maybe they don't even want the drink
just say here's five bucks can you give
it to the wrong McDonald's can figure
that out yep but first of all why
wouldn't you want something because
Founders is like incredible one of my
favorite places to get a coffee but not
just coffee you guys have amazing food
there too tell us about some of these
Delicacies pastries coffee cake really
good we just added that avocado brought
a toast which we just added as well
super good oh wow yeah and then we have
quiche House made can I try one of these
drinks yes yes the oatmeal cookies so go
in get a drink help the Ronald McDonald
House and you guys have a couple of
locations right we do one on Durango and
Sunset and one on St Rose and amigo
which one is this oatmeal cookie oh my
gosh it tastes just like an oatmeal
cookie and you guys didn't put the
raisins in thank goodness
now if people want to donate to Ronald
McDonald House cherries on their own how
can they do that yeah you can visit our
website at
www.rmhlv.org it's such a great
organization if you've never been to the
Ronald McDonald House maybe you can't
donate your your money definitely do
your time it's so great and Founders
this is so great that you guys are doing
this thank you so much for making our
community better I'm going to enjoy this
and send it over to Ted with a look at
your most accurate weather now for